a shocking murder capturing just how
dangerous liberals have made America's
cities Tech Titan Bob Lee stabbed
multiple times to death while walking
around one of San Francisco's most
expensive neighborhoods and Nancy
Pelosi's District Lee told friends that
the city was deteriorating into a
cesspool and had moved to Miami but was
back for a business trip after being
stabbed twice in the chest he staggered
through the streets and tried to get
help from a passing car but it drove
away police have yet to make an arrest
and a cop association's blasting the
city listen
we need to change it around because
perception is reality in San Francisco
that you could commit a crime and
basically go through a revolving door in
our criminal justice system and be out
Elon musk's responding to the shocking
murder quote many people I know have
been severely assaulted violent crime in
San Francisco is horrific and even if
attackers are caught they're often
released immediately is the city taking
stronger action to incarcerate repeat
violent offenders at Brooke Jenkins
that's the D.A their judge I mean we
always ask the same question what is it
going to take for the city to get things
under control is this it
uh they say that this is a Tipping Point
everyone says that I've spoken to in
California says that this is something
that has hit us hard but let's try to
figure out how we got here you've got
woke California woke San Francisco Nancy
Pelosi Chessa Boudin who didn't believe
in locking up criminals he believed in
letting them go free and then mayor
London breed who cut I believe it's 120
million dollars out of the police budget
and the police said if you do so it will
take longer for us to respond to
emergencies Ergo the six minutes it took
to respond to Bob Lee as he lay there uh
begging people to help him
um you know London Bree now says she
wants to refund the police after she
defunded them as if any of them had a
half a brain and defunding them in the
first place but they've got a lot more
to do you've got to make sure that the
people are who are being released over
and over again are kept in and until
someone defines social justice I still
don't know what it is to me I think it
means you've got to let criminals out
and let victims be subjected to their
continuing assault and Anarchy but San
Francisco one of the most beautiful
cities in the country the tenderloin
district is now a place where you
fornicate you defecate you do drugs out
in the open and you live out your mental
illness the people in charge of that
City need to be thrown out I like the
new D.A I do like the new D.A I think
she's going to make a difference and uh
but I'm confident that unless they
decide to you know put the blame where
it belongs on the criminal and stop with
the social justice nonsense it's never
going to end and this poor guy he
contributed Bobby Lee so much to society
but that Society did nothing for him as
he showed his injuries to a car that was
idling and then begged the police to
come and get him horrible and it's also
on the hill of the vicious attack on
Paul Pelosi that should never have even
been in this country
he's from Canada Jessica sorry I was
trying to get to where you were and now
I remember that he was from that very
dangerous country up above and address
if you ask Paul I I totally agree and
once that tape came out everybody was on
the absolute same page about what
happened to Paul Pelosi and what an
incredible Injustice went on and how
dangerous it was and and all of that I
agree with what the judge said the new
D.A who I thought her response was spot
on about this she's been declarative she
was replacing someone who was hounded
out of office by the people who put him
in there I mean it was a coalition of
Asian Americans who were sick of being
attacked on the streets and they had
been behind chess of Odin originally
they were incredibly pivotal
constituency in Democratic politics in
San Francisco and they said enough is
enough with this it's so sad to me I've
spent a ton of time in San Francisco
my father's favorite City my husband
used to live there we went twice during
the pandemic
completely changed right somewhere where
you wouldn't even think about as a city
person that you would be raising a
family
um it's an interesting question now and
we said the same thing after remember
there was a guy who worked at Goldman
Sachs who was murdered on the subway
going to brunch one Saturday is this
going to be different because now the
big Banks aren't right this is an elite
where this happened and that's certainly
the case here with Bob Lee someone who's
a tech founder San Francisco doesn't
exist without Tech Founders right that
they bankrolled the entire city and I
know he had already gone to Miami so
does this change at a faster Pace
because it's not a nameless person I
don't know we had an Olympian who got
smashed in the face in Los Angeles right
and and nothing seemed to change from
that but I really hope something does
because these
American cities are worth
saving from this they're beautiful and
they're important and it's just a
terrible tragedy how does Nancy Pelosi
always Escape accountability I mean you
have Mayors and DA's who come and go but
Nancy's represented San Francisco
forever and she never says anything when
these things happen it's the same year
like if you think about Chuck Schumer
when does he comment about never crime
in New York City I mean that you you Nev
and AOC remember when all the women were
being victimized and the women being
thrown in front of the subway she never
said anything and so new to Kirsten
dillebrand right so there is something
about them being able to say well I'm in
Washington so I don't have any
responsibility there fine it is sad that
even after going through the recall and
getting Chessa Boudin out of San
Francisco that the D.A as good as she
might be she's in this deep hole and she
doesn't have enough resources and the
police are demoralized as you heard
Tracy McRae say and then this is
happening in all these other cities as
well in Washington DC over the weekend
there was this horrible crime of a a
tourist who is there gets followed in to
her hotel brutally beaten attacked it's
horrible and stad and then you look at
the guy's rap sheet a million miles long
and so I don't know what sort of circuit
breaker the country needs in order to
reset or who could who it could be to
lead us out but you would think that
something like this would let people
figure out that our cities are in a free
fall and that is dangerous I agree with
Jessica when they do find this perp I'm
sure he's got a rap sheet a mile long
Wilkin I'm sure that to be the case you
know you want to be optimistic and I
think New York City under Rudy Giuliani
offers you the the Ray of Hope that
these cities can be saved but then you
know real time makes you a pessimist
because it's not just San Francisco to
your point Chicago just
ousted Lori Lightfoot and brings in
Brandon Johnson which is going to be if
not more of the same more extreme of a
similar type and so you know and this is
the same city the past five million
dollars in reparations for people one of
the qualifications of which was if
you're a descendant of the War on Drugs
anyone who's been incarcerated for the
War on Drugs there's nothing of Hope to
offer you there in San Francisco and to
me the the most depressing part of this
is the is the the note in the story that
he approaches a white Toyota Camry and
lifts his shirt up to show the Stab
Wound and the car drives away that's not
just the decay of City leadership that's
now the decay of your populace as well
what would you have done absolutely
helped that individual absolutely rolled
my window to God out what's wrong with
you and you know what Jesse doesn't make
me special that makes me normal in most
of the country I don't live in San
Francisco I live in Texas and let me
promise you I would be right down the
middle of the course that's par for the
course all right you are normal and
you're special thank you very much Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now